[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
hopefully
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
this
[Music]
audio
[Music]
yo yo yo yo
[Music]
you guys should be able to hear us um
hustle
is having like work stuff going on with
him like he got a new job
you know how it is sometimes when you
get a new job
you gotta
gotta commit man
so we we we got dirt in here though say
something dirt
yo what's up what's up
you guys know we gonna be we're gonna be
really
really spicy today
you guys read the topics you know what
it's up
we got
death stranding playstation playing
dirty and uh
and xbox after the deal
i kind of want to just talk about a
little bit about what you know maybe
is xbox's future after they uh
finally buy that
because i feel like we've been talking
about the
this deal for so long it's kind of
unreal that it seems like it's about to
end you know what i'm saying
yeah exactly bro i mean yeah you're
right about that we've been talking
about it since january
and it's been a huge thing in the xbox
community
and it's like wow it's it's it's almost
you know there you know i'm saying it's
almost about to come to an end where
it's going to be official huh i said
they can see you now by the way
oh okay might as well just go live we we
it looks like big cloud late again
oh nice cut appreciate it man
gotta yeah look at the fresh cut
i was talking to cog and uh he was like
look man he's like i'm not telling you
how to live your life
but you got to get your hair cut by a
black dude
he's like if he white leaf
oh man
yeah so uh appreciate everyone come
through this the attic show
where we talk about the past
present and future gaming i got got dirt
griggity here man what you been playing
what's going on dirk
what's up man you know surprisingly you
know what i've been playing man
i wanted to finish the last of us two
again
i
booted it back up because the first time
i finished i kind of rushed through it
because i was trying to review it
properly
um so i said no i'm going to take my
time with it you prepping up for that
slander when the other one comes out
don't you
well you know
uh no comment on that but
i
played through it again and and i have
the same thoughts about it it was a
decent game but that story was really
just
it's almost like the story got worse
the second playthrough
even though i knew everything was going
to happen just some of the decisions is
just mind-boggling i personally feel
like the direction they should have took
that game and i know i could i get
clowned on when i say this dirt it makes
no sense but
i feel like what would have been better
is
joel didn't die at the beginning but
tommy did and the game is about
you chasing after joel trying to revenge
his brother
and you know imagine like coming across
scenes like uh you know that courthouse
and
like where there's just dead bodies
everywhere but it's
joel you know what i'm saying right just
yeah you finally come across joe towards
like the middle end of the game and he
sacrifices himself to keep you alive
like
i just felt like that would have been
the better one that that's
well you know i didn't have a problem
with joe dying like you said it just
first two hours of the game
that was come on man come on and and
then like forcing you to play as the
person that killed him for like 10 hours
of the game
and
realizing she's not a bad person and you
actually start to like her a little bit
it was just so many bad decisions and
like like the gameplay was decent the
graphics were great
it was just the story just i don't i
don't understand some of the decisions
uh yeah you know i just don't it's like
i said you know i understand why they
did the way they did
uh i disagree heavenly i feel like
there's a thousand different different
areas that they could have took that
story than they did take that story
uh just to me it's like come on man like
you could do this better you could have
done this way better but it is what it
is uh what you've been playing besides
that man is that all because i know that
game takes that game is a little too
long if you ask it's definitely a long
game um i think it's you know at least
about look six seven hours too long i'll
be playing um i've been playing 2k i
haven't really been gaming a lot lately
they got us like a lot of stuff going on
in my personal life um so that's pretty
much the only thing i've been playing 2k
the last of us two
so
i might go back and play miles morales
because i never really finished it i
might do that game great game i actually
like that game more not like the
original spider-man in 2000 okay
spider-man come on 16 or 17.
hey uh spider-man came around 18 18 it
came out the same year god awarded
yeah that's why 2018 you know having a
pro xbox channel was real difficult to
be honest with you let's be real it's
kind of hard yeah it was xbox channel
all last generation yeah and i was and i
just started off like in 2017 i was kind
of project scorpio was my first like big
topic and that one was a positive one
but by the time 2018 hit and you know
they had god of war spider-man
detroit become human they had all these
big games coming out it was it was
difficult xbox really didn't have
anything but cfds and save the k2
and i think they did release forza
horizon
4
that fall but
yeah so it was it it was rough well you
know i made it through it
it's good i've been playing cold the
lamb i've been playing a lot of that uh
what's that
cold what's the name of that
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i keep on
hearing about that yeah it's good it's
definitely uh so far it's a very unique
game uh kind of reminds me of
moonlighters i don't know if you've
played that it's on game pass
moonlight is like
that see where i didn't play during the
bit errors a lot of them i played like
towards the last of the 32-bit i think
that's what the last one was called it's
like the 8 to 16 to 32-bit right is that
what they're called
yep a6 i played i played at the end of
the 32 you know the last couple years of
that so you know i i don't know what is
technically like zelda
um
like a link to the past what bit was
that
was that 16
well i don't know about nintendo [ __ ] i
mean stuff
yeah but you get what i'm saying like
yeah yeah it's it's like that
moonlighters it's pretty much like you
you explore caverns you explore dungeons
and then what happens is after you
explore these dungeons you loot these
things you kill they drop stuff you take
it back to your actual hometown and you
you are merchant like you own stuff and
you put it up there to sell that's what
that game's about and you know that's
the only way that you actually level
stuff up is doing that so it's it's an
interesting thing and i i think people
in the chat definitely if you try to you
know if you got game pass like download
it it's a very good game code of the
lamb it kind of reminds me of that now i
will say i right now i'm i'm feeling
moonlighters more
um i feel like cold of the lamb has a
good mechanic system when it comes to
like micromanaging but i don't know why
just like the interaction of like oh i
just did a whole dungeon i just had a
really good week like because you every
day
pretty much you take the stuff that you
got from the dungeons that move lighter
you go back to your store and you sell
it
uh so
and it's it's it's weird because it's
like you have these like four
little uh tables that have like it's a
it's a it's a two by two so two on the
top two on the bottom and you can
upgrade your store in moonlighters and
make it more where you can have three
five then you can have someone that
helps you so you don't uh so they don't
rob you like you eventually you get to
the point where people walk into your
store grab your stuff and start running
you have to run up to them and grab them
before they get out
and then you know obviously you take
that money you invest into the town you
invest it to bring more merchants into
the game
it's a very
core game now it's different than cult
of the lands but it's got a lot of the
same aspects as court of the lambs but
both of them seem like fantastic games
definitely you know go out there and try
it out now uh code of the lambs isn't on
game pass
uh so i know a lot of you in the chat be
like addict i'ma wait and feel further
away here's what i'm saying if you want
to feel like you want to wait for a
triple a game
okay wait for a triple a game
but when it comes to these 20 25 indies
let's go out there and buy it man you
know these are small teams like you
wouldn't believe just
what takes millions upon millions upon
millions to make these big publishers
and stuff happy
take like five hundred thousand to make
a developer happy it's like you know go
out there spend that 25 man you gotta
spend that at mcdonald's you gotta spend
that at mcdonald's
i mean i mean at this point you might
even spend more than that yeah hell yeah
you might go to mcdonald's for a family
yeah you spit
you wha what what a kid's meal six bucks
now isn't it something like that like
stuff like that got this van you got
this
uh so you know like i said definitely
try out moonlighters because it's in
game pass right now and then if you
really like moonlighters uh then go out
there and drop that 25s and try that
game all right let's let's get into it
man we we got a great show going for you
guys we got death stranding apparently
rumored it's going to pc game pass as in
rumored it's pretty much happening i
mean i even think the official game pass
pc came up in there and they they
announced that they might as well have
announced it we got playstation playing
dirty apparently they're going around
with these publishers saying yo i don't
like game pass i'm gonna give you a
blank check don't put your stuff in game
pass and then we got xbox after the deal
i just want to go over with dirt and you
know bit cloudy shows up eventually you
know
what we think is the aftermath what
we're going to happen afterwards and you
know we might got a little bit of small
topics meeting uh dirt talking about i
know there's a lot of stuff going on
about forsaken the uh
uh for spoken i keep messing about that
name for spoken apparently uh people
think it's cringy acting well you know
what's crazy when people say that game
is cringy i'm like have you ever played
jrpgs
ever
yeah go play five minutes of kingdom
hearts and tell me it's cringy
they're all cringy
but anyway man let's let's let's get on
with this man well first off let's talk
about this death stranding thing this
this thing going good man
it's i woke up man first off let me tell
you guys let me tell you guys i woke up
to king being messy in the iop chat of
course messy messy he said he
you know obviously he'll probably have a
problem if i say word for word what he
said but we'll re we'll read a couple
what king said so he posted and he says
oh no cognito posting says oh and then
king just post gifts over and over again
gifts over and over again
laughing gifts
king loving this if if you guys think
this is gonna be good
just wait till sunday man just wait till
sunday which you know we're gonna have
an industry guest on sunday um so
maybe king won't be as messy because we
we've been trying to like pull that back
a little bit during that so we don't go
too extra when it comes to that we got a
two dollar super superstar from fandom
kraken
dirt why don't you get a haircut like
attic never mind man that that's jackie
hey you know what now that's my wbz
brother now why would you say that joey
that hurts that hurts me deeply fanny
cracking you should you should feel
ashamed of yourself how dare you sir
uh so you know
obviously we see this death straining
thing what do you think
when you first saw this is first off we
we both know that you laughed you opened
it up you saw it and you just started
laughing driving down the road we both
know let me i'm gonna i'm gonna show you
my exact reaction okay i got my phone
i'm scrolling through my phone
[Laughter]
you know you know when they first posted
that in there
i kind of thought they were saying it
was coming to xbox
for a second
i thought it said it was coming to xbox
and i was like
this week's about to be lit and then i
saw a pc game they need to kind of take
that xbox pc game pass thing like just
call it pc game pack you don't need to
put xbox in that name you're confusing
me man you're making me think i'm have
to have a lit we can end up being
downgraded i don't want that man we're
gonna be interesting in here but you
know when i saw this i'm thinking
yo
so
how is it that mike
first off let's
let's let's throw all the stuff on the
table dirk
who let's go who owns the publishing
rights to that stranding
for the pc i believe
or
okay i believe a console with sony for
pc i believe is is it five or five games
yeah 505 games you know what's crazy
about that too i'm kind of
confused because
my uh to my knowledge sony owns this
that stranding ip don't they
but yeah i think they do i think you're
right and people are right people
sitting there like oh you know this is
this is kojima kojima is the one that
said this and i'm like
how is someone that owns the ip gonna
walk up and someone that doesn't own an
ip is gonna look straight at them and
say i'm putting
yo [ __ ] on someone else's platform makes
no sense to me this is sony letting this
happen guys this is nothing else more
than that sony owns the ip of death
stranding if this whatever happens with
death training that is result of sony
letting it happen
um things have changed addicts
things have changed and just a few years
if people would have said sony would
allow a gang well their games go to pc
first off no way in hell with sony allow
their games go to pc their game sale on
like xbox
i know you remember hearing that because
i do
now sony not only allowed their games on
pc but now we're seeing them allow
a game that they own
a a ip that they own that they
technically own
to go to xbox game pass on pc well i
mean well it's not that weird nowadays
because
i can't hear you
i'm talking on the phone just uh oh oh
i'm sorry i saw your mouth movement
but not only that
with mlb the show being in game pass it
really shouldn't be a huge surprise
at this point but it is funny
it's definitely funny because death
stranding was a game that a lot of
people
um cap for a lot of people dislike like
myself a lot of people like
but at the end of the day it is owned by
sony and it is going until
game pass for pc so yes
this is funny
i have to admit this like some of the
things that's been happening this
generation so far with some of the
decisions sony has made
i believe it's going to benefit them as
a platform and and as a company
but you know
it's funny for the playstation fanboys
and their reactions that's the funniest
thing to me
to see their reactions to to see them
cry and complain about what sony's doing
for them to threaten to to to bomb the
uh
playstation buildings for them to lose
their minds that's the funniest part to
me that's the entertainment
yeah it's crazy
yeah man so
mlb was forced by by a i don't care who
was forced but is this funny that a you
know a sony first party team is
developing a multi-plat that's in xbox
service and here we have another game
that's owned by playstation that's in
a xbox service
and
that's what i'm saying we we got to be
understanding here that
this is happening like it's you know
it's it's the naturalization of stuff
you know even with sony owning it i i do
think kojima has
some bargaining power when it comes to
it i'm sure that he wants to make a
sequel i'm sure that sony to a point has
to be realistic with the matter
regardless what happens i don't know
but
you know
i think that
this is something that's just standard
now obviously we can joke about it you
know it's funny it's funny and we're
joking mainly from the aspect of these
playstation fanboys that you know
cried and died this game and now this
game somewhere else
that's what we're mainly talking about
this but the part that's just the part
that's just funny is just like this
happens you know
don't be surprised if we get hit with
that
sunset overdrive too on x playstation
only you know don't be surprised that
that happens and
uh you know the way this
is going i wouldn't be surprised if
sony's already green lit you know
because that's a bad look on it on on
playstation
you know it and what i think is funny is
like people act like that spider-man
and like the marvel universe on
playstation is like in concrete it's not
right now they have a good relationship
with marvel we don't know the future of
that we don't know if the next time
because here's the thing regardless how
good that spider-man game is doing or
wolverine or whatever they decide else
to bring to it the fact of the matter is
at the end of the day sony uh marvel
don't care about that you know what
marvel cares about that spider-man ip
on
on the the movies they they want that
and if that starts going south do you
not think everything else is going to go
south of course
marvel might be like all right because
you know let's say sony wants more money
the next time okay you know we ain't
doing this we're just gonna write them
out of the story
and uh once your contract's up that's
all
like you ain't doing no more with the
games you know and i'm not saying
there's a chance that's gonna happen
there's probably a very lit slim chance
but the way this industry works don't be
surprised if anything changes at the
blink of an eye
yeah i agree this is a different time
man where there's things that's
happening us as gamers never
thought would happen some of the stuff
we're seeing going on nowadays this is
it's just a different time so i
wholeheartedly agree with you
we just can't assume everything is going
to be great forever between marvel and
sony we just can't assume that we just
don't know man um
things are changing and um we just don't
know what uh what will happen next i
never thought i would see xbox about to
buy activision blizzard that's why i
never thought i'd see some stuff like
that
it is what it is you know i just think
that
it's funny how things work out
i think that's when it comes down to it
you know
that's why i always encourage people
don't double down on stuff on twitter
no yeah and and never say never yeah
you know even when it comes to you know
games being on playstation only or xbox
only
yeah never ever put anything in stone
ever because at any point in time in the
next couple years
things could drastically change and
absolutely that's why i'm here to tell
you man you gotta keep in mind that you
know this is the gaming industry and
it's very
it's very changeable at any time
tiles are changing constantly and i
think some people forget that some
people think that
you know just because something happened
in the 360 era it means it's going to
happen in this area so because something
happened in the next area it means it's
going to happen this area it's like
every generation is a clean start uh
everyone because if you look at it
people sit there and say playstation has
a good track record
they do but guess who else has a good
track record nintendo
plu you know people sit there and say
well
well
addict the 360 didn't win that
generation it didn't the we did
but it's like we did technically
if you want to get tactical about this
the playstation came in dead last and
people was like but at the end they
caught up yeah cause the race was over
when xbox stopped developing uh um they
stopped making um xbox 360s and at that
point like even if they stopped making
them continue making them that's
irrelevant at that point because right
the next generation that is when that
race was officially over
right like what do you cause look even
if they were making
consoles do you really think that the
primary focus is on that platform and no
it's on the pre it's on the next one
so it's just like
people acting like you're running a
marathon and you get to the the finish
line of the marathon and people like
number one go keep going then when is
the race end
right well you get to the finish line
you stop running
i love that analogy by the way
hey that's a fact
that's an absolute fact and people love
to say that xbox yeah to get a ps3
caught up even i say it appears to be
technically caught up but if you even if
you look at software sold
360 absolutely destroyed the playstation
3.
because i mean i just feel the 360 was
the box that the casuals chose that
generation
that's why the software was sold more on
the 360.
i feel you and i just feel like you know
things
things never seem what they are but you
know that's pretty much all we have to
talk about we got to see exactly what
happens with death straining in the
future um
i don't know if he'll ever come to xbox
but it is interesting that it is coming
a game pass so that means yeah that
means at some point
sony
and microsoft got into a room
and agreed that debt straining on pc can
go to gamepad that means
it just think about it
they're choosing
because they are pushing onto the pc
genre they're pushing into that market
they let
their own game go into a competitor's
platform
in the game so that kind of blows my
mind but you know we're going to go and
talk about playstation playing dirty
because it's probably going to be a
short podcast this week you know we
might not even make it to uh big cloud
shows up because there's just not a lot
to talk about this week yeah there's not
a lot to talk about yeah but you know
guess what this playstation playing
dirty is interesting man for those of
you that don't know and uh you know
anyone want to correct me in the chat
that's fine
playstation
is going to third-party publishers
and they're putting clauses in their
contract that's pretty much saying that
they can't
put game pass and they can't put their
game into any subscription service keep
in mind this isn't just
one this isn't just targeting game
passes targeting the whole
sleep as a whole now keep them we know
what they're really targeting it's game
pass
but
sony is being more competitive in terms
of you know what's the point of going
out and get these publishing
rights if they just go behind us and put
their game on game pass day and day
because then at that point
what's the point of having the
publishing rights if you don't have the
better place to play the game
so they are putting these in one thing i
want to ask you is
you know dirt do you think that this is
a competitive thing how do you feel
about it
honestly
i will be honest i don't have a problem
with what they're doing i just think
it's aggressive this is you know you
have to be aggressive in business
i don't have a problem with them you
know doing that
in my personal opinion but i do have a
problem with them being hypocritical but
that's not what we're talking about at
the moment
um i just think that
when when you're trying to gain an
advantage on your competitor
in business you have to do aggressive
moves like that you know um signing
exclusivity deals
you know doing things like that saying
yo you can't put this game in that
service because that service game pass
is a threat
it's obviously a threat to sony they've
been crying about gang pass
so that's the issue i have with them
as far as you know being hypocritical
with
um crying about game pass and xbox about
their own activism blizzard and the call
of duty franchise so i do have that
issue with them for being hypocrites but
when it comes to the question you ask me
them doing this business deal keeping
games out of game pass
i have no problem with it
it's business
yeah
i think people need to understand that
it's like look this is
sony is
first off it's amending that game pass
is some form of issue sure they might
not hear it they might not run away but
they do know that this is going to be an
issue in the future and that's that's
that's interesting
uh it's just it's it's funny it's funny
uh keep going uh my phone is ringing so
just uh keep talking about real quick
yeah so like i was saying um you know
i've said this on my podcast some
personal videos of mine i i don't have a
problem with it
but i do have a problem with them crying
that xbox could potentially keep a game
off of their platform now just because
the game is call of duty which is
obviously
playstation biggest selling game every
year
now it's gonna hurt them
and they're crying about it no no don't
let them buy this acquisition and they
admitted xbox game pass is a huge
problem like alex said
for the longest
playstation fanboys said xbox game pass
was it never was it's it's it's it's not
a threat um all those games are game
pass fighter and all that stuff but as
you see
it's a threat because playstation
mentioned xbox game pass by name
um the moves they're making keeping
games off of xbox game pass why why
would they do that if they didn't know
that
when you think about a 70 game a 70 game
and compare it to a low entry service 10
15 a month
they know the casual they're not brand
loyal like us right everybody know i'm
team xbox there's other people that's
team playstation we're going to stick to
those consoles but when it comes to the
casuals
listen bro
every generation is different the
casuals will go
what been where it benefits them
if you can see a service like xbox game
pass has not only the current and future
call of duty's but all past call of
duty's
playstation knows yo they're going to
gravitate to the xbox
they're still going to have their their
their strong hardcore people on the
playstation platform but they're going
to lose some people to the xbox
that's why they're like no don't let
this deal go through please don't let it
go through
they're not stupid
so
them um doing these deals to keep games
off xbox game pass like i said again i
don't have a problem with it it's just
aggressive business but at the same time
they're being hypocrites because xbox is
being aggressive by buying activism
blizzard so you can't have it both ways
yeah i told you yeah
yeah i'm just i'm having stuff that's
popping off at the last minute i'll hand
over here in a couple minutes i okay and
it comes down to it man
man people are really talking about my
my cut man look i got yeah man they like
your cut bro got a haircut can't help
all right it's just like
i don't understand what people expected
sony to do like they did they really
expect sony just to like okay we're not
going to even
consider that there's issues with this
that's the part that just blows my mind
and it's just like
i understand
i do
uh
do you think that you know
microsoft do you think microsoft might
start putting stuff into their stuff to
maybe prevent them from doing stuff like
this
in the future uh probably yeah there
might be some third-party games that
maybe
um i don't know xbox has a marketing or
maybe even playstation has some
marketing there there might be some
language in the contracts like yo um
we will give you guys more money to
playstation if you allow us to put the
game in xbox game pass maybe a year
later or something six months later
absolutely man that's that's that's
business you know they you know listen i
have a counter offer
you you know like you like you hear
playstation offer xbox as a counter
offer that's more lucrative like man we
want our game your game
and game pass and they might say the
benefits of the game being a game pass
if your game has micro transactions
there's going to be millions of more
people that's able to play your game and
can um get micro transactions so there
are so many different ways they can go
at it and i believe they will because
xbox game pass is obviously a huge thing
for xbox and they wanted to be the best
it can be
so playstation uh you know stopping
games from going to xbox game pass
i'm sure xbox will eventually have some
type of counter offers
i hear you i hear you
i feel like this is just competition man
people want competition but people don't
want people doing stuff for competition
like yeah this is competition i
guarantee you see microsoft's doing this
too it's just you know no
things have leaked it which is funny i
remember one uh right the last resident
evil something like this popped up too
and i think that's funny in the matter
uh you know
stuff like this happens it's just
it's just one of those things where
people just got to rotate with it so
here's big cloud which is good because
uh i gotta call my boss real quick so
you guys keep talking about this for
another five minutes i'll be back i'm
sorry
big cloud right now what we're talking
about is um
we're talking about uh sony
you know coming up there on the edge and
be like uh you know we we don't want
these games in game pass how you feel
about that
we can't hear you
we can't hear you bro you must be on
mute
how about now
are you good
nice i can't get over addict's haircut
all right so um
how many times we talked about this i
think i said it what did i say the
spoils of war at this point
this is gonna be the art of war you're
gonna see both of them try to outdo one
another at this point now again this is
not unheard of we've been heard this
before we've been saw this before sony
always has a clause
in these contracts somewhere
where you know they can make themselves
look better but now
uh
microsoft when pulled the craziest ace
card he's like you know what we got more
money than you so they bought activision
and now you're seeing other stuff being
thrown out here
now how i feel about it i've said this
on the show as a lesson you know as
business one-on-one at this point you
know you want to make one salad better
than the other that's just basically
what they're doing microsoft strategy in
this particular case and this is going
to work for them in the long run
especially when call of duty goes
through
um
especially when you're looking at the
seventy dollar price tag situation
microsoft is going to say hey look 25
maybe it's 15 i don't know how much it's
going to go up but by the time
this goes through
game pass is probably going to be going
through that price hike so let's say 25
a month you get you know all the call of
duty's get all this stuff
and you get that day one free dlc and
all that junk i can see all that stuff
being thrown in this with the consoles
limited edition consoles they're gonna
make themselves look good in that
particular aspect how does sony compete
against that it's simple sony needs to
go into their treasure chest they have a
lot of games they can use to push
engagement numbers when it comes to
online the problem is
sony's gotten lazy
and i've said this multiple times mike
sony's relied on call of duty like a
crutch
can't rely on call of duty anymore you
have to go back in your own studios
and push your own talent
that simple
remakes the last of us
ain't gonna do it
especially if you ain't got the
multiplayer connection with that and
ain't gonna do it
yeah hey can i say this right quick i
i agree with you and i think sony knows
that they have to uh like you said they
can't really depend on cod anymore
because this is about to be acquired by
xbox even though it will still be on the
platform it will still be on the
playstation platform it's just not going
to be the same when there's a um there's
an alternate way of playing call of duty
uh at a way cheaper price for
the casuals um now like the hardcore
playstation fans they're gonna stick to
playing cod on the system that they have
already but
we know there's still a lot of people
that have ps4s that have xbox ones and
most of them are casual some are casuals
because the hardcore we have the new
systems now but the casuals they haven't
upgraded yet because so somebody knows
that big you know that big deal you know
i mean like they like usually when these
consoles do crazy good there's always
like those crazy bundles you know i'm
like really they're the uncharted bundle
with the custom console the batman thing
and then they have to slam slim models
their stuff really take off yeah yeah
and i can see that again that stuff
happened
um let's just remind the chat as if
microsoft has any talent uh
less less and less and less i'm a
playstation guy you can check my stats i
guarantee my psn is probably more higher
than yours
the acquisitions that they made right
now solidify they're going to be a force
to be reckoned with as this gym
progresses let's not be naive about the
future and what's going to happen let's
be opened and look at what's going to
happen there's a reason why sony
is sweating right now
i appreciate you saying that bro because
i would be the first to admit
um last generation yes playstation i
love their first party single player
games i love their games that's like
some of the best devs in the world sony
and always shines in the single-player
aspect
that that's where their mastermind's at
so you're gonna have those still you're
still gonna have those same bangers from
sony yeah iron man three is guaranteed
to sell ps5 i mean wolverine is another
you're guaranteed to get this stuff
the problem is
they ain't got nowhere
for multiplayer what do they have you
know what i mean yeah you're gonna have
the call of duty licensed deal whatever
for what you got right now
but
what else we got afterwards you know i
mean once that deal is done we're back
to square one
yeah i mean yeah you're right but like
back to the uh the point that the guy
said he said that xbox don't have any
time look man let's be honest like i
just mentioned playstation has shown
their talent um
xbox
they knew their weakness right yeah now
you would have said what playstation
weakness is what are they doing they're
developing they bought um studios that
can help with that multiplayer issue
that they had bungie think about fire
sprite all these teams haven is making
multiplayer games so they realize their
weakness so did xbox
xbox realize talent having more studios
so we can't just we went through the
last last generation we went through a
whole gin of complaining about this i've
said this multiple times my biggest
issue last year for microsoft was the
simple fact they didn't try to compete
they literally did not try you came and
you came tonight that just can't be
denied they did not even try to compete
they sat there and just studying their
own failure
and i'm sitting watching like
that's it
what are we doing you know i mean now
we're in a different situation here
they're out here actually fixing a
problem these studios fix the problem
we've always talked about the halo gear
support to be the only things now they
have tons to choose from to push it
and when you throw that into the service
when you actually get the stuff right
when they actually get these games done
who's to say this is not gonna be a good
deal this is gonna be one of the best
deals as far as sony's concern and like
you know the new uh playstation plus
premium
playstation plus premium again people
might listen i love twitter sometimes i
love it i see dudes talking about deals
now we're the best deal in gaming but
you know we're against deals for the
longest time uh
listen
as much as i love playstations
and even sony admitted this when they
talked about this during the brazilian
uh commission
their service is not on power game bus
it's going to take years for them to get
there
and
they said that not because of no
hindsight thinking no they know that
because it's a pure fact
it's not ready yet they don't have dnd
releases on there
and you know what's funny about that too
day and day release i don't know if you
saw it do you see it
uh on the pc over there on playstation
they they actually cracked the the
spiderman joint supposedly yeah yeah and
they found that this is going this was
part of a launcher
that sony was was planning to do
for pc gaming
so this whole day and date thing
i don't know if i said this i don't know
i said dessert i mean i said this
listen
dude keep stop stop saying hey i keep
hope alive listen
it's a wrap
it's done it's enough
when you got it in the source code
you know
it's already being done as we speak it's
the reason why they tested the discounts
on playstation on steam the reason why
they're doing all this stuff
yeah i think it's coming eventually bro
it's a wrap it's a wrap i don't know
when i can't say next year i can't say
it this year i can't say it next year
you can't say but i think it's eventual
eventually yeah enemy super chats for
attic man um since he was busy god's hit
man with the five dollars i see london i
see friends i see more sony games coming
to game pass oh
no
we'll see man we'll see rubber knob with
the five
um game pass was designed and priced for
the casual market this is why sony is
concerned i wholeheartedly agree i think
some
i think sometimes us hardcore gamers we
just disregard the casuals and listen
man
if you get that casual market you're on
to something uh the ps4 was the casual
box flat out
the ps2 was the casualized ps1 i think
the 360 was a casual box
um they were the dude bro console they
had everything yeah bro working in their
favor even when they first like when
they first announced that deal with the
whole call of duty thing you know the
dlc joined yeah that played 30 days yeah
yeah that pushed the constant in new
heights nobody was expected that so it
was like yeah absolutely this is the
console to get you know even though you
have to pay for online but again
that's where microsoft used that into
their advantage they were like yeah you
know what hey that's what you get
um the angry therapist md with the tools
shout out to dirk thank you bro what's
happening with your angry therapist how
you doing man thanks for stopping by uh
that's all i have uh on my ear so yeah
this is an interesting topic man it's
just that
i just think
we all like
last generation we know xbox falls we
know what playstation did but i'm going
to tell you this is just my opinion
xbox and playstation were behind in some
aspects coming into this generation
xbox was behind
on
studios first
first party you know like like you said
it was by halo gears of force the last
generation now
because they were behind on developing
games that's why we're in the current
drought with xbox right and playstation
even though they had the single player
locked down last gen with the exception
of rockstar i think playstation had the
best single-player games except you know
like besides
like red dead 2 and some other you know
like games out there
but like you admitted their multiplayer
they like know like the game industry
was changing right before our very eyes
with this live service stuff and the
multiplayer stuff
and playstation was behind that aspect
so they're trying to play catch up in
that field at the same time xbox is
trying to play catch up in new ips
developing games you know so that's just
my opinion i think both were behind us
from what i'm looking at for microsoft
they're looking for those
like again because you've seen them kind
of slowly get into that format that
third person i could see them definitely
going in a row i don't expect state of
decay
three to look like for example last week
i mean i don't know yeah yeah i'm here
and change i'm so sorry guys uh styles
of their uh
other games but
i do expect change in that regard right
i do expect them to try and like either
not necessarily mimic but get in that
conversation you know i mean like one of
the biggest things i complain about for
microsoft is the fact that they're just
sitting here and they're not getting
into the superhero conversation you know
i mean sony's are dominated with the
marvel uh universe why aren't you
jumping on the dc train why aren't you
trying to get
you know ties in with disney over here
you know you got she-hulk introducing
daredevil why aren't you trying to get
there though
all right saying like you know you need
something so catch me up man catch me up
uh let me get this
okay
i'm just i'm getting it i'm having
issues with work right now
um got a two dollar cat uh
good old dirt what's up brother what's
up carl weed what's happening man thanks
for stopping by bro appreciate it
all right so what are we talking about
man we we i okay looks like you guys
talking about some type of a comic book
in some way
no we're just
really just
tackling the whole thing maybe we had a
good old conversation bro about you know
xbox and playstation pretty much
yeah like again i actually think that
the landscape for both is really well
right now i don't think yeah i agree
issues i agree
the future's gonna be good you guys i
see sony stepping up even further let's
say your headset's on back
i don't care that's like
but i'm sorry i'm so annoyed right now
i'm trying to like like like
calm my my inners down so so i can get
back into
into the attic character which you know
it's it's me
we seen you play among us
look i i like among us what you talking
why are you running your mouth
[Laughter]
real happy last time
oh here we go why is it always yet
that's you yeah yeah and yeah
hold up okay
he's not giving context behind this all
right
see my character in among us is to feel
offended everyone says anything about me
so that way when it is me and when it's
not me i have the same exact energy and
it's and what what big cloud is failing
to tell you is one time we was playing
among us and i killed someone right in
front of him and all he saw was me and
the blood and because i had that same
energy all the time
guess who convinced everyone in that
room that i wasn't the killer
i was like
immediately emergency beat him so it
popped up first thing i said okay big
clay let me talk let me talk okay
i was like let me explain what happened
i was like i got there and the dead body
was there i'm not saying it was big
clout but i'm saying it was suspect
i'm like guys he's just what i told you
like well okay we can't afford to lose
all right so
what i did is i threw all the blame on
big cloud because i talked first and
then big cloud couldn't come at me
anymore so he had to defend himself and
i convinced everyone to just vote no
vote
wow
funny stuff
what's funny is the person i killed when
the game was over was like how you guys
gonna big cloud literally caught him
caught him exactly
exactly
you know
funny stuff
oh my god
hilarious good times amongst good times
uh the microsoft uh sony um
i see too much like really
i don't wanna say reaching
i just think people need to just chill
and both sides are gonna be fine
at this point sony's not gonna be
nothing to worry about microsoft's
definitely not gonna have anything to
worry about i do think though
like going forward it is gonna be
interesting
uh just to see how
things progress
uh going forward that's for sure
and uh
like i said before competition's always
good competition brings out the best
so we've been seeing a lot of you know
i don't want to see arrogance on it but
we've been we've been seeing a little
bit of a chilled
laid back you know i mean
lazy
type of sony in a sense we've been
getting the bangers but not the stuff
that we've been asking for not the
features a lot of us been asking for
worse gifting we got wishlifted wish
listing on ps5 where's the gifting
option you know i mean like where's all
the other stuff that we were hoping for
you know we're seeing remakes of games
that we didn't ask for
instead of re makes for games that we
need
i'm just saying
so
that's where i'm at in the whole thing
thank you brother
oh i'm having everyone calling me under
the sun yeah that was oh man he's one of
them days that was the girlfriend i had
to answer that one real quick but um
yeah i i i think people need to realize
that
this isn't the ps4 generation i think
people keep acting like just because the
the the playstation
beat the complete dog stuff out of xbox
last generation
that that that's going to happen this
direction the problem with that is
is
the mindset for microsoft at the
beginning of last generation and the
mindset for microsoft at the beginning
of this generation they're not the same
last generation microsoft wanted to get
to continue doing gaming but they wanted
to make their console more of a we're
going to focus on everything and let you
have access to a media box not a gaming
console
this generation they're focusing on the
gaming portion and they're saying look
you can play games but it plays netflix
it plays hula plays everything and
that's the difference between the beasts
now last generation microsoft didn't
have that that gauntlet you know they
didn't have that thanos scotland they
got some of the best studios in the
industry right now working yeah they
pretty much had assault you know they
they had some of the best studios making
games right now sure maybe a lot of them
are aaa
double a but the difference is is you
got stuff like obsidian that's always
made quality gains but never had that
that that that push to go to the next
level you got exile entertainment that's
always made good games but they've never
had that push to go into the next level
now keep in mind they've been making a
lot of games that i like like turn-based
stuff the moment microsoft acquires them
they're making a triple-a
like fallout type of game
yeah they are yeah
and not to mention they have them yeah
not to mention they might be working on
a wasteland 4 that we don't know about
so
yeah man like when you have a company
like microsoft backing you
and
it's not about how much the game sell or
you know it's is not about pitching your
game to publishers
i remember tim shafer said you know the
the best thing
about
getting acquired by xbox is they don't
have to shop their game to publisher
hoping to
hoping like to get some funding to
finish this game or crowdfund the game
like the whole thing with psychonauts 2.
i know you guys heard him and uh
interviewer adam sessler adam sessler
asked him when you guys got acquired by
xbox how what made i mean like how much
did the game change and he said yo we
could put every boss back into the game
because they had to take the bosses all
of the bosses in psychonauts 2
will would not have been in that game if
xbox didn't acquire it and they delayed
the game for a year and we saw how great
the game was so
these companies being being backed by a
company like microsoft is game changing
man so i mean like you said
and that's how i was doing you know like
again like smaller games
now they're they're doing it man huge
triple a can make dream passion projects
yeah absolutely
with money behind them um
so it's
it's gonna be a good gin like a lot of
people need to understand that like it's
not one side of where sony's just the
only person here
on the big stage with games no it's
legit going to be
like a back and forth thing you know i
kind of see it as funny as the funny
reference but i'm kind of thinking of
like wwe right now like under the triple
h administration not even going notice
how there's change you got characters
who got removed they're fired coming and
they're bringing them back and the shows
have gotten progressively better it's a
prolonged change thing you're going to
be seeing over here things are getting
progressively
better you're seeing more of an
aggressive nature come back you're
seeing that proper tone come back you're
seeing you know um
drive kind of coming back in a sense
from microsoft and that's the good thing
about it sony what sony got to do sony
just has to get back what matters and
that is pushing the games that truly
matter yeah i don't push those new ips
put those new you know those new
characters out there that's not remake
games
that we've already played
already
on two gens let's not do that
let's get
og classics yeah i mean give those back
there maybe like you never know you
might catch lightning in a bottle with
socom because you know what's happening
you might catch lightning in a bottle or
resistance
you might catch lightning in a bottle
with uh twisted metal you know i mean
like there's so many games they have
at their disposal that they can be
bringing back here and i'm not even
counting evo
this is where you get aggressive this is
where you hit up capcom
this is where you get that resident evil
license yeah i mean you have to go
all out
and use those relationships to the
fullest and god forbid sony pulls off
something with from software because
they are they hold uh well they're like
one two percent in the company but
they have a crazy working relationship
with them i mean i'd be surprised what
they do
yeah
and what's funny is
you know we're going to get into the
last topic on uh
on what's going to happen in the future
of microsoft but
you know because fortnight being kicking
we're going to talk about that real
quick
you know
i'm i'm going to uh give a dragon ball z
reference i don't even think this is not
even a dragon ball z i don't
shut up
fraud the fraud even the dragon mossy
thing and i
j i'm gonna give a reference man i don't
you think xbox is on their final form
this ain't they final form likes
like they they
they in the middle of like i feel like
they still got one more evolution man
they they they that goku getting getting
kind of like still beat you know they
they've powered up it's kind of like
equaled out but i feel like i feel like
i feel like they got one more form man
they got that that evolution form with
that that vibrance is just going off
their chest you know they got
i feel like microsoft got that man you
know you're gonna eventually see
microsoft pop up with the 18 pack
you know they go sit there you just
you're gonna be able to throw glass
against their chest and just gonna break
no scars nothing you know they they
all generation they've been having a
hand up getting that getting that spirit
bomb and you know i don't know if
they're gonna be able to hit my sony
with the spirit bomb they might they may
not miss
but uh you know we'll see if they hit
them uh but you know
i do want to talk about the fortnight
thing with dragon ball z real quick uh
you know
it's kind of crazy
how big
i haven't really look dragon ball z has
always had been a very popular anime for
years but it's kind of crazy how
fortnite was like yo
we're going to give you a kamehameha
we're going to give you this the
transformation
and we're gonna we're gonna rock it
and then you look at what's going on
and it's like everyone is playing
fortnite right now i know people that's
never played fortnite well they've
played they haven't played fortnite in
three years they pop it on they spending
30 to 50 bucks on skins they probably
never going back on that stuff with
i'm seeing people content creators get
their communities together jump up in
the air and kalai kamehameha waves like
20 people going down a line like it's
just
i got i got i mean i don't know how you
guys feel but i personally feel like
we've gotten to the point
where fortnite is the most influential
game in history
they have
they have
broken that line to it's like look we
name another game that's done this many
collabs name another game that has
forced cross progression and cross
platform on almost every big game
in
the gaming industry that's true this is
this game started the battle where y'all
uh yeah royale craze
like whoa
but you wouldn't have got this big yeah
it wasn't yeah yeah but this kind of
took it around it's kind of like popular
i guess it's the word it's debatable
yeah it's debatable if
they wouldn't have done what they did
pub g might not even be around right now
because if you think about it they made
the franchise they made that whole genre
more popular than what happened
so now you have more people playing that
genre and they're going back
and they're trying pubg there's a world
where pub g
where fortnite never switches to a
battle royale they keep that defense
thing that game dies in a year and that
was trash yeah no kid like i honestly
think
there are games in history that have
drastically changed the game landscape
call of duty halo
league of legends i think that's one of
them you know there's games out there
wows change the the mmo portion of
everything there's games out there that
are essential to the gaming industry
that cause them to be where they're at
and these games for the most part are
more they have done more for the gaming
industry than the actual companies that
make the consoles
it's just like i don't know of another
game that has done more than than than
epic and in fortnight because it's like
i said they
i'm i'm convinced a world without call
of duty i mean a world without fortnight
call of duty is still playing call of
duty's not a cross-play game
call of duty is not a cross-progression
game destiny's not a cross-play game
destiny's not a cross-progression game
and people say attic all they did is
give the option look i get it they
didn't force these other studios to do
but what i will say
is that micros is when you force a
company as big as sony to bend the knee
on something that big and that creative
what you did is you set a standard
and then after that
the other people they can't fight
like
when sony
let the pandora's box open and they let
cross play everywhere into fortnite then
that gave call of duty and activision
and like look dude you like you let them
do it
why didn't you let us do it
right and i feel like those
conversations are happening behind
closed doors that and then keep in mind
it was still they were still stubborn i
think remember there was there are
rumors and i and i believe them
that
bungie
went to the multiple times to make
destiny 2 a cross play game and they
kept denying it over and over again
and bungie was about to go without them
and they they called like the last like
week before they went live and because
it it's crazy
like you know i think now
at this point it's it's everywhere even
their own first party games are doing it
now like the show
like we are going to eventually live in
a world where games are going to clown
on if they're not cross-playing
cross-progression uh and i love it
because i feel like you shouldn't be
damned on playing with your friends on
what platform you're on the only thing
that should incentivize the platform
that you're playing on
is first party and third-party marketing
deals that's all you know timed
exclusives you should never get held
onto a console because your friends are
there that's why you see microsoft doing
stuff like discord if you guys don't
think that sony and nintendo are
eventually going to follow behind on
that you're mistaken all it takes is one
of those japan companies doing it to
make it more of a standard for the other
one to do it now sure i will say
nintendo might not do it but if sony and
microsoft are doing it the odds of
nintendo not adapting sooner or later
and there's a reason that they would
adapt it's because of cross play
they need that
you know and there's not a good you know
there's a lot of games that people don't
know like that don't have no also has
the fixture online though too though
yeah what
no i said nintendo has to fix your
online infrastructure to begin with
though
they're like farther behind they're like
the
worst in this case right now they're
like the worst [ __ ] it's like i said man
all i want is these
these companies to do better it's like i
don't i don't
we might come up here even dirt we come
up here we do the console joking stuff
and i get a lot of flack for the console
stuff i do i don't i'm not as extra dirt
you know you guys like the you like king
go go watch go watch dirt's podcast
his is he's he's it's a fun time man
you're gonna laugh the whole time you're
there uh
[ __ ] clown spicy as you say spicy it's
really spicy but kyle likes to like to
dip his toes in a little bit but for the
most part
he ain't really doing too much console
war stuff
but you know you got you got guys like
that a little understated see here
console wars
is is good for the industry but they're
the bad qualities of the console war
outweighs the good qualities by far yeah
and that's the issue we're having
just go to twitter you'll see the
long-term drop yeah people people's
brains are mush on twitter now
spaces ooh
i actually you know someone in the chat
man this is an ideal and you know feel
free anyone to take and i ain't doing it
because i got too much [ __ ] i'm doing
make a show called
youtubers versus spacers
and where it's literally just youtube
people versus space p spaces people and
his debates
that's all
nah it's like space is like the worst
invention ever it just gave the
those who shouldn't have a voiceless
voice
and then i never thought i'd see david
jaffee
complete such a just do such a homicide
like i saw a couple it was it was
terrible
dirt knows what i'm talking about yeah i
know what you're talking about
i'm like yo
again why are you dudes even trying at
this point you don't know what you're
talking about nobody cares like it's
just
mm-hmm
i
can't i can't remember let me let me
address the truth differently you know
not this particular chat but we got
people
that come into iop and it's not just one
you know i think um the thinker is a big
component of it uh he's real big on like
timestamps and stuff and like look i get
it timestamps make podcasts a lot easier
to navigate
but what i want people and it's not just
a thinker there are other people that
ask for timestamps we don't owe you
timestamps that's a luxury
um iop does time stamps because someone
else does timestamps you ain't gonna see
attic do time stamps it ain't happening
you know i i
what i've been trying to do is be better
on at least going in there and telling
you when the starting student screen
ends because i feel like that is valid
criticism to at least know when the
starting student screen ends but as far
as
knowing
the duration of the podcast first off
this is less structured than the than
the iron lore's podcast we're everywhere
i don't even know what topic we're
talking about at this point
uh and i'm not trying to like
you know attack anyone in the chat that
asks for timestamps i just want you guys
to realize that you know first off this
is free content
you ain't paying for this
you know some of you might want to throw
some super chats in the chat and we
appreciate that it's amazing but at the
end of the day
this is free content and we don't owe
you time stamps i just want that to be
clear
hey that guy did you say that um
the thinker you know
nothing against him but he's one of them
guys that's never happy
there's been plenty of times that he i
don't like what you're talking about in
this video i don't like you talking
about playstation family i don't like
you doing that hey they said you can't
please everybody people are going at me
okay that's not a luxury that's just
being lazy damn straight that's being
lazy i ain't doing it
uh cycle game legit question if your
show what uh if it's your show why
wouldn't you put time stuff in your
podcast for your fans
it's not the fact that i don't have time
to do it right now i just don't i got a
lot of stuff going on it's like i said
we have a legit person that does it for
iop and for those of you that don't know
timestamps isn't something that's done
in like 10 15 minutes i gotta skip
through the podcast
i i did it i did it for um zaire's
podcast uh he he was giving me a little
something to do his time stamps they
take a minute to do probably 30 to 40
minutes to do correctly
now
and it's like i said like i think that
i'm gonna test around with the stream
marker thing because i do i understand
your criticisms i do and i'm not saying
that you guys don't deserve
that you don't deserve any form
of timestamps i'm just telling you i
don't have time to do the time steps
like
you know most of the time here's my
thing too dirt sometimes this podcast an
hour and 20 minutes
hour and 30 minutes
you guys need time stamps for three
topics
yeah yes
i'm sorry
we know how to do
this i mean yeah and that's another
thing people in there sit in the chat uh
dj great point
i don't know if this is the point you
would but i i i am manipulating your
point to my point
go look at every big podcast weaponwood
park has ilp go look at every bid
podcast
them people aren't doing their time
stamps
someone watching is
am i right or on my wrong
you go look at the comment section other
people are doing their timestamps why do
you expect different from me
it would help the channel grow and i
agree with you it did it would help the
channel grow but i i think
time
jeez
that as an attic timestamp this is a
time step topic you piece of [ __ ]
you guys are ridiculous look i do think
what i'm gonna do to try to be a little
bit because i am having artwork redone
for the podcast the last one i did i
didn't like it that much that's why i
never really went with it
how would you guys feel if i changed the
color off of the topic we're on
if i just pushed a button to change the
color
i feel like that's that's a compromise
don't you think that's a compromise dirt
you see a different color it's a
different topic i feel like that's
compromises
so like if it was nintendo turns red
blue from playstation green for xbox
no
maybe see i guess that would make sense
but why is it there's two nintendo
topics back to back
you can't you can't like separate at
that point just keep it ready but then
yeah then i'm gonna get people in the in
the chat that's like attic separate the
xbox topics
yeah if this uh xbox topic you keep it
green
i guess it's just okay
i see everybody's point right
i guess you have to find a way that's
easier for you right
with my podcast at first when i started
doing timestamps
i did it how you say i will wait after
the show listen
find it and that was no i said there has
to be a better way than this
so i figured out a way for me personally
i
i use stream yard so the time is always
in the upper left-hand corner
of like the show
whenever we change topics i write it
down
and i write it down to my notepad right
next to me so
with me by the time the show ends my
timestamps are ready because i wow
while my panel was talking
i would put the timestamps in on in the
in the description now that's what works
for me
so i just think if you really want to do
them you got to find a way that's easier
for you
if if not you know there's always other
ways like you said you know get somebody
to
you know i know because i ran in um jazz
show they have has a door he does time
stamps in the comment section
jazz will pan them
you know so so people can go right to
the time stamp so
yeah there's there's there's ways around
it
that's what i'm saying it's like look
the attic show's not big enough
to to get the the people doing the time
steps okay look i like what dirt said so
how i do next week so use my handy dandy
phone like right here in my phone
and i will put in
live
what's going on
and then i will put it in afterwards
now i can't i will start doing that from
now on
if you guys just get off my back over
okay
because i like that because that because
because what's if you if you go to the
actual screen
on um
on
the dashboard
of youtube it actually tells you
how far into the podcast right yeah you
know when we switch then i'll just go
ahead but here's the thing okay i'm
gonna make this clear
you're only getting the timestamps of
the topics in the title
you're not gonna get the random stuff i
feel like that's fair
i feel like that's fair because if i go
on some long rant i ain't gonna put that
here's the thing you guys you guys got
to be
uh some people want that they'd be like
hey i don't want to hear this round
then that's fine then there there is
there's time stamps in the comment
section to take you to the next topic
you don't need to do that all right so i
appreciate ever coming through uh you
know i appreciate you guys for uh just
give me that that input and i i
understand like i said
i understand it's important i do
i just you guys got to understand that
first off i don't get paid for this
no one gets paid for this uh people
don't realize how much time we put into
this stuff and we don't get paid like
it'd be different if like someone big
was backing us and we were all getting a
paycheck to do that i do all the time
stamps that you guys want i take i will
timestamp when attic speaks i will
timestep when dirt speaks hell our
timestamp when everyone starts burping
two minutes and 55 seconds big cloud
burp three times but guess what we ain't
in that realm right now okay we're
trying to go that direction i'm trying
to get the whole channel monetized like
that but it ain't there right now they
can make their own time sense
all right so uh all right so let's let's
talk about the future of xbox xbox after
the acquisition of activision
what do you guys think
do you think they're going to buy a
studio another one do you think they're
going to wait a little bit like how what
kind of time frame do you guys think
we're looking at
i think after the activism blizzard deal
has gone through
they're gonna you know focus on that for
i say around six to seven months
then if something pops up they will buy
a couple more studios i don't know if
they'll get another publisher
but i can see them get a couple more
studios
if available i want to point out to the
chat right now i'm going i'm gonna do it
live
you know
i'm making the timestamp one hour and 15
minutes we talking about
xbox after the deal all right so now get
get off my back man i do you talking but
there ain't gonna be time stands for the
first two topics
i'm not going back
so like i said
i um i do believe like part of me
believes that
if xbox wasn't in the process of of the
activism blizzard deal they would have
been the ones that bought crystal
dynamics and um and like the other team
from
square enix you know you know i really
would believe it like especially at the
price they got them for
300 million xbox one would have bought
them with the quickness that's my
opinion but they were in the process of
the activism blizzard deal so i do
believe they're going to get a couple
more studios afterwards who obviously i
don't know
but yeah i definitely see that because
they they want to make sure
the xbox game pass has consistent
content from their first party and
unfortunately it's taking time
but they're going to have so many teams
making games at the same time to where
they're going to have
you know like these teams are going to
have time to develop games
you know because nowadays these games
like quality triple a games take about
four to five years easy and they're
gonna have that time
so yeah i do see them buying someone
else though
yeah um
do you got any like curiosity maybe
who would you like for them to to
purchase after this oh that's that's
easy right there is it wb
yeah
i mean they'll be
just listen they can another round mr is
the top of my list
rocksteady uh
what's the ones that's making or um yo
gotham yo this comment i'm sorry
yeah
so let me
microsoft should buy comcast and throw
to the internet speed for ps4 oh wow man
mondays oh man come on oh no
oh yeah
um
that'd be aggressive right there i gotta
say another round
rocksteady and um wb montreal i think
that's the one that's made the main
gotham knights yeah
i feel you guys man it's just i i think
oh we'll go ahead and let big cloud what
what do you think's going to happen
after that big cloud do you think
they're going chill for a little bit
or you think they'll come out there and
big bait tank little bank again like
right after that
i mean obviously they're going to chill
a little bit they're going to make their
money back as much as they can then
um
more likely just go for another studio
again i don't think we're going to see
another big publisher like this yeah uh
just to avoid the drama
that they just went through over this
monopoly yeah i don't think because
because they if they were to just go
through all this drama and go hey guys
you know let's let's say
seven months after this right they go
into now and tell you about the way
sega
belongs to us now you know i'd be like
it's gonna literally be the word it's
gonna be the scenario all over again
you're gonna have dude turn to
conspiracy theorists oh it's a monopoly
but you know if sony bought you know
bungie oh it was a great strategic thing
you know it's it's it's business
one-on-one again yeah but um
i see games being bought for this i
would like to see wb montreal for sure
just to get into the superhero
conversation like i said before but they
couldn't do that
um jesus there's so many other things
they could do
i don't think capcom would be
in their
arsenal if they were to try i don't
think capcom would be on the list no
square enix and capcom seem most likely
to be inbound for playstation so i don't
think those would be
obviously or on in the way but there's a
lot of other things they could do so i
don't i don't think that would be the
case it would just be more so of okay
what can we
i guess bring the life at this point
like what studio could we go after to
bring something so
who knows
that that's where i'm kind of i don't
think anything massive
i know that people ain't gonna agree
with me on this but
and activision makes sense for them in a
lot of different standpoints but i can't
lie to you if i didn't look at that and
say i wish it was saga
you wish it was sega yeah he wasn't a
singer singing here see the world over
activism blizzard over activation of
blues
oh you know that's you wish you didn't
you you would have liked that over i
would i would have traded that i don't
think sega would have moved a needle
like division yes
see here's the thing i i think sales
wise you're you're 100 right sales rise
you're 100 right there's nothing sega
could ever do
but as far as like what the platform
needs i i don't think they needed
activision they had a lot of activision
already all i had to offer
uh but i think they do need a japanese
branch and you know obviously you can
get both i still think you can still get
both easy
um yeah i think they still might end up
buying something like a sega or
something uh because now people don't
realize sega separated themselves from
sammy in corporation like
all their finances everything is
separated
uh so i think people need to realize
that stuff as well
um
i'm not saying that they don't need
activision i'm just saying like as far
as me as a gamer and what i like and
what the type of games that i want i
don't really resonate with a lot of
stuff that activision makes i'm happy
that they bought them because i know
that the value that those brands
especially uh you know call of duty can
bring to the xbox brand especially game
prize but as far as like the games that
i like
it's just not there you know i was more
excited about bethesda because bethesda
actually makes the games that i enjoy
uh it is what it is when it comes to
stuff like that um i feel like they need
a japanese branch um if they don't have
their own if they don't buy a publisher
they need to make one you know
over there
find someone that is very reputable that
has really good connections to to the
eastern part of the world
you know i was once that one time i said
kojima
you know pay him a lot of money
to you'll probably have to buy his
studio unfortunately
but you know
you get him in the branch you make you
make him ahead of all that branch and he
goes out there and gets double a studios
to bring into that publishing unit get
you three or four maybe five and then
have him do the same thing
that um
um
that
uh what's his name does uh for for
bethesda what's that dude's name i can't
remember
peter something isn't his name
behind pete hines yeah pete hines have
him do the same thing that pete hines do
and then you know platinum i don't like
platinum but i think platinum would be a
good game to put under that japanese
branch get you about five four five six
prominent
quality double a
you know triple a
pub developers put under one person that
has a lot of you know a lot of clout a
lot of recognition in the eastern part
of the world that he has these relations
already because that's what you're
really buying him for you're not buying
him you're fighting because he has those
relations and then sooner or later when
those games are making uh games and
they're going into game pass you have
games to
advertise to the eastern part of the
world because it's
missed walker i love it miss walker you
know get a green light a lost odyssey
too a blue dragon too you know that
that's the stuff that i feel like they
need to do and i think it would be good
i think that you know buying sega as a
whole would be fine too uh you know tago
and you know maybe takeo could be the
head of it but
i don't know i don't think that they're
i don't know if they have the relations
that would require to navigate those
eastern waters if that makes sense to
you guys
yeah
i got you um can we all just come
together for one thing though
competition is good always bro finally
we got it that's all i'm happy for i've
been asked for that for the longest time
so i used to get you know added heated
back in the uh
old times didn't i did that
you mean the uh the dark times the dark
times the dark side was strong when you
guys had nothing i just rubbed it in
your face yeah yeah yeah hey y'all y'all
let us know too
i mean you know dude's still trying to
now but it's like listen they got a lot
yeah i think you know
you can only be honest to say yeah you
know y'all can run with 2022 as foster
had no triple a games that's fine
but you can't deny
um the future road map i mean you know
that's but that's the thing that some
people
try to ignore
um
the future road map is looking really
good
so that's all i gotta say about that man
pretty much 2022 was a disaster
for xbox in every conceivable way think
about it there's the first party yeah
but um you know we got we got
250 plus people in here hit that like
button man let's get this over 100 likes
you know we coming here every day every
week to give you guys a show i apologize
for last week i ended up getting stuck
on [ __ ] for
19 hours i was at work
damn yeah that was rough that was rough
and by the time i got home it was like
it was like 6 7 30. i was like i'm going
to bed i'm not i'm not [ __ ] right i'm
going to bed
uh but you know
one thing i will say about the the the
gentleman that i have acquired you know
it's funny i've acquired
is uh you know we we keep us we keep it
light-hearted man we we we might go at
each other a little bit over like some
some light console stuff but we all know
that it's not serious man uh besides big
cloud it's serious to him wait what
life okay uh now like even with me yeah
like we do console and stuff we talk
trash but we do we usually just cracking
jokes having a lot of fun man
19 hours is that even legal uh it is if
you're in the health industry because
they can mandate you
yeah
yeah so i got mandated they mandated my
ass they they pretty much told me i
couldn't go home until they said so and
i said okay
damn she did
yeah it was it was it was stupid
but you know i appreciate everyone for
coming through you know i think it's
like i said this you know we'll go ahead
and uh let big cloud uh talk about his
perspective on trash death stranding
coming to pc game pass
uh you you missed that part of the
podcast so how did you feel about you
know garbage death stranding coming to
get pc game pass
that's actually the only game pass
pc game pass it's supposed to come to
game pass pc game pass
i might actually play now
you're not going to play that game stop
it
uh as someone who platinumed that game
put a lot of hours into that game um
how do i feel about it well first of all
i remember correctly they announced the
sequel not too long ago right they said
dead space all right i said that's
touch training 2 is happening and
um
yeah yeah and tom yeah so yeah they did
say that's happening so
uh going back to this um how do i feel
about it i mean i really
don't really have a feeling for it
whatsoever i mean a lot of dudes who
probably are getting bent out of shape
of it going to pc game pass need to
understand one thing one thing clear
it was never sony's game it was hideo
kojima's
project that sony helped fund and push
that's it
that's really it
so whatever that game was going to do it
came down to kojima he had to finally
say whatever that game goes
yeah so i
i don't know i don't know about that
well it's it's kojima's game that didn't
sony own the the ip
they
i'm pretty sure they own the trademark
to death training let's they own the
trading market i appreciate it on the
trademark probably but i know for fact
it's not theirs it's kojima say it's in
his contract i mean he might have a
contract that says that uh
yeah i mean
if you own the trademark own it like i
know i just googled it and it says sony
owns it yeah they do now yeah i just i
just googled it that's what google said
yeah sony interactive
pc 505 published for pc sony yeah
in the in in in the words of king sony
went up on the platform they looked down
to the sony passes
and
let me finish my joke real quick they
look down to the sony peasants and
they're like
i got one thing to say to you guys about
death training you're not enough we got
to take this the pc we got to get the
bag from microsoft we got to do
everything we can with this this game
because you guys want enough you didn't
go out there and support it what
happened with that dir i thought it was
important to support the developers what
happened to that i bought my games
you buy some video games
[Laughter]
what's funny is you know sony's very big
on coming out there and saying if a game
made a lot of money have i have i seen
any tweet for them about death stranding
[Laughter]
nothing for death shredding nothing for
horizon
oh horizon well that
was that ah we know what happened there
but you know a lot of dudes don't wanna
i don't wanna know what happened that's
why they were talking down on that game
see you know what they should have done
is they should have came in there right
before they dropped that game and shot
an arrow into eldon ring's knee
like this
they should have crippled elderly
because they got into a ring with a
behemoth and got slapped out of that
ring
dude man there was so much it was like
one of those
is that one of those things where they
come in they look like anime they
slapped him and he just slapped him
straight out of the out of the colosseum
you just see you know uh the you see way
up at there at the top you see horizon
and eldon ring it's just some giant
behemoth just slapping them up there you
know what kills you about that game
though because that's another game i'm
happy i platinum because that's one of
the best games we've gotten but
it's funny these guys gave us
bloodborne it's one of my favorite games
a lot of times those game that got me
into souls
s games in general
i never thought i would see so many
people flip on this studio and say
they're overrated
because it doesn't have the playstation
on the studios
they're saying they're overrated
hold on man is big cloud calling out
these playstation fanboys man i mean
listen i've seen dudes flat out come out
here and you can check their stats uh
they're like oh you know elder ring is
easy it's trash you know
harass forbidden west is is better and
i'm looking at their stats look at the
trophies
they didn't beat elder rings the
trophies determined that that is a lie
they only beat one boss and elder ring
people but they're like well i beat a
whole bunch of bosses it's easy it's
easy huh
it's easy huh
but you only be one main boss we got a
two dollar superchat from gamer by
choice great show guys it's always a
great time
and then
then you go
horizon east west one one three in the
chat is saying big cloud is pandering
banner
i don't know maybe are you pandering to
playstation oh my panda i don't know i
don't know man
horizon anyway horizon as well i'm
looking at the horizon join dudes have
me and beating the story for horizon
platinum both these games and the funny
thing is i took the long route for
horizon because i had to wait for the
patch to fix the uh 60fps mode and the
game wasn't looking too good on 60fps
but still
it's just fine don't you like
he's braiding up people lighting them
this he plating them that cause that's
pretty impressive
i got to see your paypal statement see
if you paid anyone to platinum
and you look at my psn where like the
like the platinum logo is it says zero
you know what you know what dirk you you
have zero because he paid you to do all
of his you don't want to play it
but uh no no see the platinum thing
okay so the platinum thing i don't it's
just this is i added a little extra
layer when i'm showing that dudes listen
now that i played this game i went the
extra mile you know i'm saying half
these dudes don't do that majorities
dudes don't do that they just run their
mouths about they'll they'll beat it
once and they'll talk about it for
months like it was a great revolutionary
experience
when they're not playing it and they'll
act like they're still playing it you're
not playing it
well it always freaks me out when the
game goes to pc and they act like oh
they're all emotional over it it's like
you're not playing it
you played it one time and you were done
actually now but last actually there was
so many driving so many damn games it's
wild
like can we just move on can we just get
past this
yeah
we all got to play the games right we
can't be like added man we can't be like
attic we can't we we can't play bleeding
edge i've been talking about for three
years here
oh
we can't play bleeding edge i i most
likely
so you want to know how many i beat i
want to know i asked you first
you just want to add one to whatever i
beat
like so you're going i asked you first
and the person that asked first is the
one that gets the info first so how many
games have this is the youtube street
these the youtube streets oh so so
you're watching videos on youtube is
that what you say no no i said you're
watching games on youtube yo dirk
you saw it here first you heard it here
first he said that he watched these
games in the youtube streets i in it i
don't know i don't know what he's
talking about there but okay
why are you always lying
i don't know what he's doing there
so funny man we got two dollars
subscribed from flame hey now big club
leading edge was a game it was a game i
guess i actually like bleeding edge i i
don't think
the issue was that the content the issue
was i do feel like microsoft let them
just get that out the gate with no
intentions on supporting it afterwards
that's what it seemed like yeah i i feel
like
i feel like that game could have done
something if you know they they would
have worked on it a little bit more and
they they didn't but it is what it is uh
you know i enjoyed what i played of it
but we're gonna uh
tie this up man we're gonna get do these
outros you know what i'm gonna do though
one hour and 34 minutes so i'm gonna
push enter and i'm gonna say outros
and then one hour and 34 minutes so
where
what's going on with you uh big cloud
uh you already know my channel big cloud
gaming every friday rsd podcast will you
just find me 5 p.m eastern standard time
um i have not dropped any contest meant
to drop
a few things i can get a chance to uh
we're dealing with a uh while we're
getting over a death in the family i
buried my uh
cousin when we said goodbye to my cousin
so uh that's what's going on there
but
we'll be getting back to that
i guess hopefully tomorrow maybe i'm not
really sure just been healing for the
whole time
and uh
really stayed away from social media i
haven't really posted much
as really i'm just doing all that stuff
but i have been gaming
just trying to get away from a lot of uh
energy i guess you can say so i hear you
that's what's been going on with me man
what are you doing what's going on with
you what you doing next
uh actually i'm uh i'm a guest on uh
boomsticks uh podcast at seven o'clock
um
so everything kind of worked out
for me today because i thought i was
gonna be late because i had some
personal stuff to do but that only took
an hour thank god so i was able to get
here
um yeah so boom finally invited me on
the show i'm gonna go to his podcast
after this you know
you know have a little fun i guess
that's what's up uh and you know you
guys
uh
we are having a an industry guest this
sunday
i'm not telling you guys last thing i
need is cogs like you know you supposed
to be telling people that so we we we
have a
he's never been on iop
uh he i don't even if i should give you
guys hints man i'm scared to call you
if you like you don't know like no one
is like very few people's probably seen
cognito in person he's a very built
person this dude could squish my head
like a lot like a watermelon this is
huge
well but you know uh
probably friday saturday you'll know now
it's not phil spencer
um if
it's in the chat i will let
i'll let a couple get said first
and then i will it's not jim ryan
why people when you say you're having
industry people people go with the the
craziest
person that it could possibly be
it's like no it's not but you know i
appreciate everyone for coming through
we're going to uh
end this up on a good note you know uh
we got we had big cloud dirk griggity
you know definitely go follow both of
them uh
twitter because uh they they'd be posted
especially dirt man dirt there there be
be messy on there i think you guys will
enjoy his stuff you know i actually
don't tweet that much but my channel you
know it's a lot of fun though
i don't get access to fools
you get access to them i don't post that
much all right so i appreciate it for
coming through and we're going to go
ahead and end this uh definitely put uh
you know put your your your channel in
in the chat dirt before we yeah that's
it right now
before we get out of here thank you um
you get it
[Music]
appreciate you guys
tell me when it's
why they still say timestamps i'm not
timestamping anymore uh they got two
timestamps from me so definitely go to
both of these channels man subscribe you
guys uh you know you like our clients
you'll like theirs and without any
further ado i'll talk to you guys later
gaming addict
big cloud and dirt out